>> From the Library of
Congress, in Washington, DC.
>> Stephanie Marcus: Good morning.
I'm Stephanie Marcus from
the Science Technology
and Business division
here at the Library.
I'd like to welcome
you to today's program,
which is the transiting
exoplanet survey satellite,
lovingly known as TESS.
The program is the fourth in
our 2015 series of lectures,
presented through a partnership
with our division and NASA Goddard.
And this is actually the ninth year
that we've had this wonderful
relationship, and we've been able
to bring these very
stimulating talks to the Library.
And we are definitely looking
forward to our tenth season
and starting to gather topics and
get the speakers for next year.
This year we still have
a couple of programs.
One in November and one in December.
And in November, we're going to
hear about asteroids, meteorites,
comets, yeah, popular topic.
And then in December, we get
to hear about the Pluto flyby
that everybody's been talking about.
So please check our website
and come to those talks.
Today, our speaker is Dr. Stephen
Rinehart, who's is an Astrophysicist
and the Associate Chief
of the Laboratory
for Observational Cosmology
at NASA Goddard.
Dr. Rinehart knew as a little kid
that he wanted to be a scientist,
and he also decided as a child
that he was going to go to MIT,
which he did, and that's where
he earned his BS in physics.
And then he went to Cornell
for his MS and PhD in physics.
He was a postdoc research
associate in London,
and we won't talk about that.
He seems to think that it
was very difficult to live
in London as a graduate student.
And then he was able to get a
National Research Council postdoc
fellowship at NASA Goddard,
and he's been there ever since.
He became a full-time employee
there in 2004 as an Astrophysicist.
And his wife is also
at NASA Goddard.
So they have one child who's named
Joshe, which means star in Japanese.
And he said, of course,
what else would a couple
of astrophysicists name their child.
And his mother-in-law is
here, she's right there.
All I have to say beyond that is
exoplanets, the Goldilocks zone,
alien life, these are things
that humans have been interested
in for a long, long time, even
going back to the ancient Greeks
who wondered if there were
other worlds like ours.
So I think that Dr. Rinehart
can let us in on some
of those secrets that
TESS might tell us.
Please welcome Dr. Rinehart
to the Library of Congress.
[ Applause ]
>> Stephen Rinehart: Thank you.
So that's a great introduction.
My daughter Joshe is
also at Goddard,
they have the child development
center there [laughter].
She also occasionally comes
by some great pictures
of her working in my lab.
But don't tell labor people.
I'm very happy to be here
today to talk about TESS,
the transiting exoplanet
survey satellite.
Before I really talk about it,
I'm going to give credit
where credit is due.
It's being built in partnership
by MIT, NASA Goddard, Orbital ATK,
and a number of other partners.
The principle investigator
is Dr. George Ricker at MIT.
Now, this is going to be the
next NASA explorer mission,
and it's really focused on finding
new planets around other stars,
new exoplanets, particularly
those around nearby bright stars.
So let me really start
out with a little bit
of context, and, in fact, history.
Humans have known that there
were planets besides the Earth
for a very, very long time.
In fact, the ancient Babylonians,
over 4000 years ago, around the turn
of the second millennium, recorded
observations of Mercury, Venus,
Mars, Jupiter, and Saturn.
So as long as 4000 years ago,
we've known that there were other
planets in our solar system.
We only missed 2, Uranus
and Neptune.
That's pretty amazing.
So we've known for a very, very
long time, longer than the Greeks,
that there were other
planets out there.
Nobody knows this, this is like
an obscure fact, by the way.
If we skip forward in time from 4000
years ago to about 400 years ago,
there was a guy that some of you
may have heard of, Giordano Bruno.
Bruno was a famous
astronomer of his era.
A very, very well-known, very
well-respected astronomer.
And in 1584, he laid out a
postulate, and his postulate was,
that if you look at the sky
and see all these stars,
all of those stars
are suns like our own.
Around each one of those
suns there could be planets,
and some of those planets
could be like Earth.
And on those planets, there could
be life forms, something like us.
And, fourth, and most
importantly, from his perspective,
those life forms could have souls.
Now, that last bit is what
got him burned at the stake,
and I'm going to not talk about
that all because that's theology
and philosophy, not science.
But we know that the other 3 parts,
we know that the first one
is essentially correct.
While stars are, in
fact, very, very diverse,
our sun is a star like many others.
We also know that the second
part, that there are planets
around all those stars, that's
pretty close to true too.
There are lots and lots of
planets around a lot of stars.
As for the third, that maybe there's
life on some of those planets,
we have a little way to go.
And hopefully, within my lifetime,
or my daughter's lifetime,
we'll actually be able to
talk about the possibility
of life on other planets.
And at the end of this talk,
I'll say a little bit more
about how we might get there.
So let's just jump forward again in
time, to now to about 40 years ago.
I don't know if any of you are
science-fiction fans, I am.
But if you looked at
science-fiction works that were made
in this century, whether it be
in TV, movies, or literature,
the idea that there were
planets around stars, in fact,
planets around a lot of
stars, is ubiquitous.
It just assumes to be true.
Now, at the time of all of these
works, there was no evidence,
direct or indirect,
of a single exoplanet,
a single planet around
any other star.
We had not yet found
any evidence whatsoever.
And yet the human imagination
said, they simply have to be there.
Now, all this changed
in around 1989,
when someone made the
first measurement
that showed it was possible
for us to find exoplanets.
And this kicked off the
great exoplanet search.
In fact, this week, ironically,
because we didn't really think
about this when we
scheduled this talk,
this week marks the twentieth
anniversary of the first discovery
of an exoplanet around
a main sequence star.
Since we realized we could do
it, people started looking,
and things have taken off.
In fact, you'll notice
in one second,
I have changed the scale bar,
in 2014, because there were
over 900 planets confirmed
last year alone.
So to date, we have, and
I have to look at my slide
because the number keeps
changing, as of Monday,
we had 1892 confirmed exoplanets,
planets around other stars
that we've actually been
able to observe and measure,
mostly indirectly, but we
know that they are there.
Now, you'll notice on this slide
I've got all these different colors.
That's to indicate that there
are a lot of different methods
that people have used
to find exoplanets.
And they all have advantages
and disadvantages.
But the 2 that I want to talk
about most today are the 2
that have been most successful.
And also because they have
the most relevance for TESS.
The first of these is the transit
method itself, and I'll describe
that method in more
detail in a minute.
But all of these, all the objects
that are represented by the red part
of the bar, are transiting
exoplanets.
And over half of those
planets are transiting planets.
And in fact, over 1000 of the
confirmed planets were discovered
with one mission, the Kepler
Mission, which has looked
for transiting exoplanets.
I'll say more about
Kepler in a bit too.
The other topic, the other
method I want to say something
about is the radial velocity method.
Those of the objects in blue.
That's the oldest and most venerable
method for finding exoplanets.
And it has a very important
role in how we follow
up on observations from TESS.
And I'll say more about
that in a minute.
So what are all these objects?
I'm a scientist, I like
plotting things, so bear with me.
If you look at the vertical
axis here is the mass
of a planet, in Jupiter masses.
The horizontal axis is the duration
of that planet's year,
the orbital period.
And what you can see is that
if we plot all of these planets
that have been confirmed so far,
they're really pretty
much all over the place.
They're largely up in this corner.
There's not a lot down here.
But there are even
a handful down here.
Although those yellow ones
are awfully hard to spot.
To give you a little bit of context,
let me add in our solar
system planets.
Now, there should be
a couple of things
that strike you right
away about this.
The first is that there are
only a handful of exoplanets
down in this regime where our
own planets lie, in this plot.
Now, there's 2 lessons
that I take away from that.
The first is that finding
planets like the ones
in our solar system is
really, really hard.
In fact, it is easier to find
planets the bigger they are,
pretty much no matter
what method you are using.
Which means we're bias towards
finding things up in here.
It is also, for the
most successful methods,
easier to find planets the closer
they are to their host star.
So things in here.
So it's no surprise, the first
planets we found were all
up in this range.
And as we've gotten better, as we've
gotten better at the techniques
and we've explored new techniques,
we've pushed that boundary down,
until now we're starting to just
now see some of the planets that are
like those in our own solar system.
The second thing I want to
take away from this is, to me,
actually more interesting.
And that's that while there
aren't a lot of planets like those
in our solar system, but gosh
there are a lot of planets here.
So while our solar system
planets are down here,
we don't have anything
like these objects.
These are completely new.
These are things that we never saw
until we started looking
for exoplanets.
And for theorists, this
has been a big problem.
Now, most of us, probably
not the guy
who wrote this particular theory,
but most of us like new observations
like this because they
overturn theory.
They make us say that the theory
is no good, we need a new one.
And that's always pretty exciting.
We've found a lot of things in this
data that we never expected to find.
Let me give you a couple
of quick examples.
There's the hot Jupiters,
also known as roasters.
These are Jupiter -sized
planets, but they're in orbits
of less than about 10 days.
They're closer to their host
star than Mercury is to our sun.
They're boiling hot.
In some cases, they're so
hot that you can see evidence
that there are comet-like
tails, as the atmosphere
of the planet is being boiled off
and blown away by its host star.
Again, if you talked to
a theorist 25 years ago,
and you told him this
object existed,
they would tell you you were nuts.
It makes no sense, it
shouldn't be there.
And yet now we know that they are.
And theory has evolved to
explain why we actually see them.
Another class of objects we
didn't expect were what we call
the super-Earths.
Again, if I went back in time,
and I talked to theorists,
what the one thing they
would've told me is that,
the way that planets
form is that it's easy
to form a rock about Earth size.
Once you get beyond Earth size,
if you have enough material,
you go into sort of a
runaway accretion mode.
You just grab everything
that's nearby.
So you race straight
from Earth sized
up to Uranus sized with
nothing in between.
So if I were to look at a thousand
exoplanets, I'll see a bunch
down here, and I'll
see a bunch up here,
and I won't see anything
in that box at all.
Obviously the theorists
were right -- I mean wrong.
Because that box is
very well populated
with lots and lots of planets.
And these are the super-Earths.
Now, again, we have no examples of
these planets in our solar system,
so we don't actually
know what they're like.
Now, on one end of the large end,
things like a 2 Earth radius planet,
those are probably more
like Uranus than Earth.
They're probably big icy balls.
But on the low end, something that's
say 10% or 20% larger than Earth,
well, that's probably
a rocky planet.
It might be Earthlike.
It might even be habitable.
So that leads me to the
topic of habitability.
The habitable zone and
the goldilocks zone.
Before I talk about that though, let
me give you a couple of statistics.
We have found, like I said,
almost 1900 exoplanets.
And from those studies, we've been
able to draw some very serious
and very important inferences
about the population of exoplanets.
So, for instance, we know
that in our galaxy there is
approximately 1 planet per star.
That's not to say all
stars have planets.
Some stars like our own have many.
Some have none.
But on average, there
are as many planets
in this galaxy as there are stars.
That's amazing at just
the sheer number
of planets that are out there.
We also know that about 1/6,
17% of all stars have Earth
sized planets around them.
Again, this is, you know,
shocking, 1/6 of a very,
very large number is
still a very large number.
That's a lot of Earth-sized planets.
That's a lot of potential.
And perhaps most interestingly,
22% of stars that are
like our sun have planets
in their habitable zones.
These are potential places
where we might find life.
Now, what do I mean
by habitable zone.
This also known as
the goldilocks zone,
for reasons that will become
apparent very quickly.
It is the range of distances from a
star where you can have liquid water
on the surface of the planet.
If you get too close to the star,
then the water gets too hot,
it boils off, it then evaporates,
and you're left with
a dry dusty rock.
No water. Not really a
great place for life.
If it gets too far
away from the star,
then all that water precipitates
out, it freezes, it turns into ice,
and now you have a rocky
ball that's covered
with a thick layer
of ice on top of it.
Again, not really a
great place for life.
But if you're not too hot,
and you're not too cold,
if you're just right, then you
can have all the conditions --
one of the key conditions
for formation of life.
Now, you'll note, of course,
that where that habitable
zone is is different
for different kinds of stars.
On this plot, these are 4
different kinds of stars.
And you can see that
for a small cool star,
the habitable zone is closer than it
is for a star like our own, which,
it's not hot, but it's hotter,
where it gets much farther out.
And you can see, these are some of
the planets that we found that are
in the habitable zones
of their host stars.
These kinds of objects are going to
be really, really exciting things
to study over the next few decades.
In addition to all of
that, there's a couple
of really wacky things
I always like to mention
because I think they're weird.
We have found planets
around binary stars.
Think tattooing, for you
science-fiction fans.
We have found planets in
highly eccentric orbits,
orbits that go really, really close
to their host star but then come
out past the orbit of Earth.
No particular reason to believe
that such an object should
ever exist, in yet it does.
We've even found planets
around a wide range
of host stars, including dead stars.
In fact, in 1992, we found
the first small exoplanets
around neutron stars.
These are the remnants, the husks,
left over after supernova
of normal stars.
And it's hard to believe, but
the planets, either formed later
or survived, a supernova.
Again, not something
we would have expected.
So all this now sort of leads
me to the topic of TESS itself.
And when I talk about TESS.
[ Inaudible ]
Shows you what we would
get in real time.
See that as the planet goes
across, the brightest the star gets.
These 3 plots on the right
are actual transit data
as measured by the Kepler mission.
And these are detections
of actual planets.
Obviously, this bottom one
here, that's a big planet.
It's pretty easy to see
that in that data, by eye,
you can observe immediately
that there's a transit there.
This top one, on the
other hand, that is --
well, I refer to that as a
statistical tour de force.
That was just an amazing bit
of analysis by Tom Barclay
and his collaborators to
pull that out of the data.
That planet was, and
I believe it still is,
the smallest exoplanet ever found.
It's smaller than Mercury.
And it really just goes to show
that this technique can be very,
very powerful in finding
even the smallest of planets.
It's not easy to do, because what
you're trying to do, remember,
is you're trying to
measure a difference.
And looking at a star, a
star is already pretty faint.
Now you're looking at a,
in the case of planets,
less than a percent difference
in the brightness of the star.
You're trying to measure
a small change
in something that's
already pretty faint.
So I've mentioned Kepler
a couple of times now,
so let me say a few words
about what Kepler is.
Kepler was a mission, or is a
mission, it's now the K2 mission,
looking for exoplanets by looking
for transits, much like TESS.
So why do we need TESS, what's
the difference between the two?
Well, the difference at its core
is largely a philosophical one.
Kepler was about finding
lots of exoplanets.
It was about statistics.
Ultimately, the goal was to measure
a quantity that we call eta-Earth,
which is the frequency
of Earth surround stars,
how common are Earth-sized planets
around all of the stars that we see.
It was not designed to get
detailed characteristics
of all these exoplanets.
It was just there to do a census.
It was the mailer that we get
every 10 years, that's all.
TESS, on the other hand, is
looking around the neighborhood
to see what things
are actually like.
It's looking only within a
well, very nearby distance,
to look for bright nearby stars
that have transit exoplanets.
It's about finding the planets
that are really well-suited
for follow-up observations,
for finding those objects
that we're going to
want to be studying
for the next 10, 20,
maybe even 30 years.
Now, this philosophy
is actually very clear,
if you look at the way the
different surveys are done.
For Kepler, it looked in a
relatively small portion of the sky.
But it looked out a long, long
way, over about 3000 light-years.
TESS, by contrast, only looks about
a few hundred light-years away,
but it covers almost the entire
sky, more than 400 times more area
of sky thank Kepler covered.
So it really is focused on trying
to find those exoplanets that are
around bright nearby stars.
Now, you're going to hear me
say bright nearby stars a lot,
because it's really important.
How does TESS do this?
Let's go to the second
part of the name.
The transiting exoplanet survey
satellite, the survey part of TESS.
Tess has 4 cameras, each
one of which has a 24
by 24 degree field of view.
So at any one time, it's looking
at a 24 by 96 degree patch of sky.
This is a really big field of view.
And in that field of view,
it's looking at a whole bunch
of individual targets
with small sets of data,
to try to find those
transiting events.
Each one of those observing
sectors is observed for 27 days.
And over the course of the year,
we tile 13 of those
observing sectors together
to cover almost the
entirety of one hemisphere.
Then we flip around and we repeat
that, and do the same thing
for the other hemisphere.
So at the end of 2 years,
we've covered the entire sky
with a coverage map that
looks something like this.
So you can see that most of
the sky has been observed
for at least 27 days.
And where those observing sectors
overlap, or those tiles intersect,
you get much longer observing times.
And in fact, up here, at the polls,
you get almost 1 full
year of time coverage.
That's really important
because it's at the polls
that that longer time coverage
that you're able to find planets
with longer periods, and
you're actually more sensitive
to small planets.
So this leads me to this question
of, what will TESS actually find?
Well, this is just a
simulation, it's only a model.
But all those red dots are
planets that we expect to find
with TESS in the core data.
The blue dots, which are impossible
to see for you, are other planets
that we expect to find
in ancillary data.
But the key ones, the core ones, the
ones that are most important to me,
to us, are those red dots.
Now, you'll see, they're
all over the sky.
Now, they are concentrated at
the polls, as you would expect,
because that's where our long
baseline time coverage is.
But there are a lot more
around the entire sky.
Let me convert those dots into
numbers, because I'm a numbers guy.
You see that with TESS
we're expecting to find
over 500 new small planets.
That's just in the core data.
That excludes the extra ancillary
data that we're going to getting.
And this is going to
be a huge increase.
We have only a few hundred small
planets that we know of right now.
So we're going to more than double
the size of that set of targets.
But that's not the best part.
The best part is the fact that
they're going to be close by.
So let's take a look, if I look
at how far away these planets are,
and I compare planets
that are known in blue,
the black dots are
Kepler detected planets,
and the red dots are TESS
expected TESS planets,
you'll see so far we've got
all red dots, a few blue.
There's the first black dot,
over 100 light-years away.
Here's the Kepler targets.
They go out a heck of a long way.
In fact, they go out
beyond the simulation.
But the TESS targets are almost all
within a few hundred light-years.
So they really are the
bright nearby stars.
Why is this so important?
Well, one of the things that we've
learned from all the exoplanets
that have been done so far, and this
is a really exciting field didn't
exist 20 years ago, but now it is
like perhaps the single most vibrant
part of the astronomical community.
One of the things we've learned
is that there's a lot more planets
out there than we expected, and
that they're very different.
They're not homogenous bodies.
They're not Earths and
Venuses and Mars and Jupiters.
There's planets that are sort of
like this and sort of like this
and like this, but
they're all different.
What we'd really like to do is
to start doing what I call
comparative planetology,
actually making measurements of
other planets that are out there,
exoplanets, and say, these 2
planets look similar in some ways
but they're different in other
ways, can we understand why.
Can we start to understand
how planets turn
into the objects that they are.
And to do that we need to actually
do the characterization measurements
to actually measure the properties
of individual exoplanets.
Now, this all starts with
the TESS data itself.
You learn 2 important
things just from looking
at the transit data
that TESS acquires.
The first thing you learn
is how big the planet is.
This may be kind of obvious to
some of you, but just in case.
The size of that dip in
brightness is determined entirely
by how big the planet
is relative to the star.
So if you have Jupiter transiting in
front of our sun, Jupiter will block
about 1% of the light from the sun.
If, by contrast, I have
Earth orbiting the sun,
Earth is this little dot right
there, it only blocks about 1/100
of 1% of light from the sun.
So, you know, that dip in brightness
is just the ratio of the area,
projected area, of the planet
to the area of the star.
Pretty easy, straightforward.
You can also note that you can get
the orbital period of a planet,
you can tell how long a year is.
If I'm looking at the
Earth transiting the sun,
then that transit event will occur
exactly every 365 and 1/4 days.
And I would go low and behold,
that planet has a year
that's 365 and 1/4 days long.
Furthermore, if I look carefully
at how long this transit lasts
and that the shape of the entry
and exit from that transit event,
I can start talking about things
like the eccentricity of the orbit,
the inclination angle of the orbit,
and a number of other
parameters as well.
I can learn a lot about
the orbital parameters
of a planet just from
the transit data.
Unfortunately, this
is really not enough.
If I were to take a bunch
of planets, as I have done,
and plot their radius on one axes,
so this is their radius relative
to Earth, and plot their mass on the
other axes, that's the mass relative
to Earth, they appear all sort
of in this band on that plot.
Now, you'll see the green above
dots are super-Earth planets,
blue dots are other exoplanets,
particularly giants up here.
And these pink squares are
planets in our own solar system.
These 4 lines, hydrogen,
water, rock, and iron,
are what we call phase curves.
They are the how big a planet
would be if it had this mass
and was made out of this material.
This is kind of obvious, right.
If I have a bowling
ball and a soccer ball,
they have the same radius, but the
bowling ball weighs a lot more.
If I have a shock put and a bowling
ball, they weigh about the same,
but the shock put's a
lot smaller in radius.
The same thing is true for planets.
If I just measure the
radius of a planet,
and let's say measure something
here at 2 Earth radii, well,
all those of those things are
about 2 Earth radii and they vary
from water-like planets to rocky
planets to planets that are heavier
and may even be iron-like.
Vice versa, if I just had a
mass measurement, then, well,
I've got something here that looks
heavier than iron, that's weird.
I've got several things that are
rocky, and one thing that's watery,
and then some things that are
kind of lying above that curve.
So if I have just radius,
it's not enough.
If I had just mass, it's not enough.
Both of those things
give me some idea of what
that planet might be like, but they
don't really tell me nearly enough
to start understanding
what it really is like.
I need both.
If I have both, I have a density
and I can tell you what the gross
composition of that planet is.
I can tell you whether it's a
lump of rock, a big bowl of ice
and water, a gas giant,
or maybe something bizarre
like an enormous chunk of
iron in the middle of nowhere.
So how do I get that
second measurement?
With the transit data,
I've gotten the radius.
Now I want to get the mass.
So this brings me to the
radial velocity technique.
The radial velocity technique is
actually the oldest technique having
been used for finding exoplanets.
And it works like this.
If I look at the light from a star
and I break that into the spectrum,
into very, very small
chunks of light,
then what I see are a whole bunch
of very narrow absorption
bands, absorption lines, even.
If I watch those lines carefully,
then I can learn a
lot about the star.
If that star has a
planet orbiting it,
then the planet doesn't
just orbit the star,
the star orbits the planet as well.
In fact, they both orbit the
center of mass of the system.
So for every orbit
this planet makes,
the star is doing a
tiny little pirouette.
So if you're watching that
spectrum, then what you will see is
that as the star comes
towards you in that pirouette,
the lines all shift a little bit
bluer, they get a little bit bluer
than they would be otherwise,
from the Doppler effect.
As the star goes away from you,
they get a little bit redder
from the Doppler effect.
So over time, I see these
lines doing this, moving back
and forth, and back and forth.
And if I measure the frequency
at which they go back and forth,
I now know the orbital period,
I know how long the
year is for that planet.
If I also measure the amplitude,
how far those things move,
I can tell you how
massive that planet is.
So if I have that measurement,
in combination
with the transit measurement, I can
tell you what that planet is made
out of, roughly speaking.
So this means that
follow-up observations
of the TESS targets are going
to be really, really critical.
And in fact, part of the TESS
program is to have people
with ground-based telescopes
following up on these targets,
to try to make the
measurements to get the masses.
This is not an easy
measurement to make.
And well, in fact, it's
extremely challenging.
So let me give you an example.
Kepler, with all those planets
that go out very, very far away,
while it has been responsible
for the detection
of over 1000 exoplanets,
1000 confirmed exoplanets,
there almost 4700 additional
exoplanet candidates
that Kepler has found that
have not yet been confirmed.
And for many of those,
they haven't been confirmed
because those stars are down here.
They are simply too
faint for us to make
that radial velocity measurement
in order to measure the mass.
So what would you like?
You'd like planets
around brighter stars,
maybe bright nearby stars, in fact.
And you see, that with TESS,
of course, the stars are about,
on average, 100 times
brighter than those for Kepler.
So for Kepler to get a mass of
some of these planets down in here,
I need weeks or months or many
months of telescope time in order
to make that measurement.
With Kepler -- I'm sorry,
with TESS, it will take hours.
And in fact, some of these stars
are visible to the naked eye.
An amateur astronomer,
somebody with 4 inch telescope,
could go in their backyard and if
they have a decent camera behind it,
could actually measure that transit.
Maybe not from DC, it's
too hazy and polluted.
But they go out to West Virginia
somewhere and make that measurement.
I think that's amazing.
So a big key difference between
Kepler and TESS is that with Kepler,
you find a new exoplanet
candidate, and you go,
can we make that follow-up
measurement?
Is it even possible?
With TESS, it's going to be,
we've got all these exoplanet
candidates, which one do we do next?
It's a problem of prioritization,
not one of possibility.
So as I mentioned before, TESS
actually has partners lined
up to make a bunch of
these measurements.
The Las Cumbres Observatory --
actually it's the Las Cumbres Global
Observatory Telescope, I believe.
Pardon, if any of you speak French,
I'm about to do something horrible.
The Observatory Haute-Provence.
My friend's pronunciation,
I keep being told is awful.
And the HARPS Instrument, which is
the high accuracy radial velocity
planetary search project.
So these are all partners who
are going to be helping us
in doing that follow-up work.
And there's a lot of
other partners here,
there's just not enough
room to put them on a slide.
Unfortunately, even once
we have that measurement,
we still don't really know
that much about the planets.
Now we know roughly what -- we can
tell it's a rock, that's about it.
Venus and Earth are both rocks.
They have about the same mass.
They have about the same radius.
They're both in the
habitable zone of the sun.
And yet, it's a gorgeous day outside
here in Washington, DC, on Earth.
There is no place on Venus where
we can stand on the surface
and be alive for more
than about a millisecond.
I like it here, I'm
not going to go there.
We were talking outside about would
I go to Mars, the answer is maybe.
I wouldn't go to Venus.
But if I just had the mass and
radius, they look the same.
I'd like to be able to
tell the difference.
I'd like to know which planets
out there are Earthlike,
which ones are Venous like,
which ones are Mars like.
How do I do that?
Well, you need yet
another measurement.
What you really want
to see is the spectrum
of the atmosphere of the planet.
Now, for Earth, this is
this lime and green here.
You see all these big deep features.
Those are almost all due to water.
Some of them are due
to carbon dioxide,
but they're almost
mostly due to water.
And that's a very good sign.
We like water on planets.
Mars, by contrast, here in blue,
really doesn't have many features
at all because it's
atmosphere is thin and tenuous
and doesn't have much in it.
Venus has a lot of features,
but they are not water features.
They are things like carbon
dioxide and sulfur-based chemicals.
It's a very different atmosphere,
so its spectrum is
very, very different.
If I had a spectrum of
an exoplanet like this,
I could tell you immediately if it
was one of -- like one of these 3,
or if it was something
completely different,
which I really think is likely.
So how do you make that measurement?
Now we're getting really
into the weeds,
now things get really hard to do.
We do that with a technique
we call transfer spectroscopy.
Now, so imagine for a moment
that you've got a planet.
And let's imagine that this
planet has an atmosphere,
a big thick atmosphere, and that
atmosphere absorbs all green light.
All red light goes right through it.
All blue light goes
right through it.
But all green light gets completely
absorbed by the atmosphere.
Then if I look at that planet,
and I watch the transit occur
in red light, what I see
is that just the rock.
I just see the rock
passing from the star.
I see the transit.
Everything is great.
If I look in blue light,
I see the same thing.
But if I look in green light,
suddenly the atmosphere is
absorbing light from the star too,
so now the planet doesn't
look like it's the rock,
it looks like it's a bigger rock,
because the atmosphere is also
blocking out light from the star.
So when I observe that transit,
I see that the transit starts a
little earlier, ends a little later,
and it's a little bit deeper.
If I do this at a lot of
different wavelengths,
then what I'm measuring is the
apparent size of the planet
as a function of wavelength.
That tells me what's
in the atmosphere.
That is a spectrum of the atmosphere
and tells me what its
composition is.
Now, this is a very, very, very
challenging measurement to make.
Remember, I talked about it before,
a transit measurement
itself is hard,
because you're measuring
the difference.
You're measuring this
change in brightness
of something that's
already pretty faint.
To do transit spectroscopy, you're
trying to measure the change
in the change of something
that's already pretty faint.
So this is an extremely
challenging measurement to make.
And if you want to be
able to make it, you need,
let me guess, bright nearby stars.
In fact, you want really
bright stars.
You want stars that you could
see through a pair of binoculars,
if not brighter than that.
These are all the exoplanets
that are currently known,
as of last night, around very
bright stars, and which transit,
and there are 30 of them.
Most of them, of course, are up
here, they're the giant planets.
In fact, they're the roasters.
But there are a few down in here.
Unfortunately, those are all --
there, A, only a handful of them.
And, B, when I say that they are
bright, they're right at the cutoff
of what I consider bright enough.
They're not really bright.
TESS changes that.
With TESS, suddenly we have
hundreds of these planets
that are bright enough
for us to make
that transit spectroscopy
measurement.
Hundreds of planets where
we will be able to go
and actually tell you
what the atmosphere
of that plan is made out of.
And in fact, with future facilities,
like the James Webb space telescope,
which should launch in about 2018,
and with future ground-based
telescopes, they are people working
on 20 and 30 meter
ground-based telescopes,
that eventually will
actually get built.
With facilities like those,
we'll actually be able
to measure the atmospheres
of planets in this range,
all of these we'll be able to do,
but we'll also be able to do some
of these small ones as well.
We won't get down to
the Earth-sized planets.
That's going to take
something even more powerful
than what's in the drawing boards.
But we will be able to do
these super-Earth planets.
And we may well find some actual
signs of habitable worlds.
And that's really, really exciting.
Now, ultimately, we
want to do better
than even these transit
spectroscopy.
Ultimately, we would like to
actually observe a planet directly
and see a spectrum
that looks like this.
We would like to see a really high
quality spectrum directly measure
the planet.
This is actually the
spectrum of the Earth,
as measured reflected off the moon.
A very elegant little experiment.
And you can see in this spectrum,
there's a lot of stuff
going on in our atmosphere.
Our atmosphere is very complex.
But there's a couple of key features
that are, to me, as an astronomer,
really interesting, and
there are things, to me,
that individually indicate
that there might be a
nice place for people.
I see Rayleigh scattering, which
tells me that there's a blue sky.
I see very strong oxygen features.
Well, where's the oxygen come from?
It comes from a lot of places,
but when they're this strong,
there's something on that
planet that's producing oxygen.
In our case, it's plant life.
Okay, it's not definitive, but
there's a strong indication here
that there might be plant
life on this planet.
Then I see water features.
I see a lot of water features.
That tells me that water is not only
present but abundant on this planet.
That there might even be
big bodies of liquid water
on the surface of this planet.
Again, this is one of the things
that we consider critical,
necessary for the formation
of life as we know it.
Then we also see my
favorite feature,
the methane feature, out here.
On Earth, methane is almost entirely
produced by biological life.
Whether it is bacteria on
the ground or in jungles,
breaking down organic matter,
or flatulent livestock,
almost all of the methane
in our atmosphere is actually
produced by biological life.
So if we saw the combination of all
of these features in the spectrum
of an exoplanet, we would have,
not a definitive, but a very, very,
very strong case that that planet
is habitable and maybe even habited.
Again, we're not going to be
able to make that measurement
in the near future, that's something
that will happen down the line.
And maybe it will be a target
that's been found by TESS.
I think it is likely that the first
time we see a spectrum like that,
it will be something
that TESS finds.
But that spectrum will have to wait
for the next generation
of space telescopes.
Which brings me to my final
actual slide, which is to point
out that TESS is part
of a long line.
Exoplanets is a new
field, as I said before,
it's really only about 20 years old.
And it's really only
been in the past 10 years
that it's really taken
off in a powerful way.
And it's built on the
legacy of a lot
of other facilities and missions.
It started with ground-based
observatories.
But then the Hubble space telescope
has made great discoveries.
Spitzer has been used
to study exoplanets.
And the Kepler mission that I
talked about is responsible for more
than half the exoplanets that we
know about, that we've confirmed.
TESS is the next logical step.
Because we're no longer interested
in just finding exoplanets,
we're interested now
in finding exoplanets
that we can actually study.
We're actually interested in
learning what exoplanets are like.
And this is a very big
departure, this is a new direction,
this is opening the door
for comparative planetology.
Beyond TESS, JWST is going
to be a critical facility
for following up these objects.
We're going to have the target list
that exoplanet scientists are going
to be using for the next 20 years.
And JWST is going to be the
best way to study those objects
over the next decade
or maybe longer.
Beyond that, the WFirst
NASA mission, which is going
to launch sometime in the next
decade, I think it's 2023,
but please don't quote me on that.
That is going to also be
used to study exoplanets.
And beyond that, astronomers
are looking at possible missions
in the long-term, something
like what's shown here is
the New World telescope,
even larger telescopes that are
optimized solely for the purpose
of getting a spectrum
of an exoplanet,
something that looks like that.
And ultimately, maybe before I die,
we will actually have not just
a whole range of exoplanets,
but we'll have a wide
variety of exo-Earths.
We will be able to
talk about the fact
that our Earth is a unique object,
but there are other Earth's similar,
similar enough that
they could support life.
And we can start understanding
the differences between planets
that are habitable, not just
the differences between planets.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> That is exciting, and I hope
we all live a really long time
so we can learn more about this.
We can have questions now.
And would you please repeat the
question so everyone can hear it.
>> I can do that.
[ Inaudible Question ]
So let me see if I can pull this up.
So the question was,
the first exoplanets
that were found were large
planets, and they were close
to their own sun; they were close
in, these were the hot Jupiters.
Have we gotten better or closer
to finding things that are more
like our own solar system?
Well, the answer is, the short
answer is, yes, we've gotten better.
Originally we found things that
were all up in this regime,
but now you can see that
there's a lot of planets that are
in the same general area as Jupiter.
There's a few that
get close to Saturn.
There's a few scattered in
here with the rocky planets.
So we are doing better,
but we have a ways to go.
One of the fundamental
limitations is the fact
that stars themselves
are not well behaved.
Stars are intrinsically
noisy, if you've looked
at sun spots or solar flares.
All stars do that at some
level, in fact, our star is,
in the grand scheme of
things, relatively quiet.
So we try to make measurements of
these planets around other stars,
we have to take into account the
fact that there's all this activity
of the star that interferes
with out measurement.
But we are getting better.
It is unclear how far we
can go from the ground.
It's unclear how far we can
go with these techniques.
But we're going to keep pushing that
until we get as far as we can go.
[ Inaudible Questions ]
Let me see if I can
repeat the question.
So the question is,
what about giant stars?
Do we see smaller stars eclipsing
or transiting other larger stars?
Do we see -- okay, I think
that's about it, right?
The short answer is yes.
In fact, we find a lot of what
we call eclipsing binaries.
And in many cases, those are 2
stars that are around the same size,
that can be very different in size.
But, in fact, one of the
biggest sources of noise
that we've got are
eclipsing binaries.
Because if you have a big star and
a little star, it produces a signal
that looks a lot like
a transiting exoplanet.
You know, if you look
at it in more detail,
you realize that's not a planet,
but it takes some extra work.
Now, as for giant stars, typically
we don't observe giant stars
on purpose.
The reason for that is that, if I
have a planet around a giant star,
remember, that signal, that drop in
brightness, is the ratio of the area
of the planet to the
area of the star.
If the area of the star is this,
then my signal drops like a rock,
and now I've got no
depth to measure,
because it's so small
it's not miserable.
So we don't on purpose
look at giant stars.
Now, for TESS, this ancillary
data, when I mentioned briefly,
is we're going to be getting
these full frame images.
We're going to be taking pictures
of the entire observation sector,
that entire 24 by 96 degree
field of view, every 30 minutes.
And anything that's in that data,
if there's a transiting something
around a giant star, we'll have the
data, it's possible we'll find it.
That will be a very difficult
bit of analysis to do.
I'll ask a grad student to cover it.
Other questions?
[ Inaudible Question ]
Earthlike planets, the
estimate is there are 16%
of stars have an Earth
sized planet around them.
[ Inaudible Questions ]
The question is that, I
quoted a statistic that 16%
of stars have Earthlike
planets around them.
I also commented that some stars
have no planets around them.
Do we know that for a fact?
And no, it's hard to
know that for a fact.
If a star has a planet in
a very, very distant orbit,
it would be very difficult
to detect the methods
that are really effective,
like transfer rate of velocity.
[ Inaudible Question ]
What we can say is that there
are some stars out there
that don't have any planets
within a certain distance,
but that's about it.
And there's other stars where we
can make theoretical arguments
that there shouldn't
be any planets, right.
If I see a supergiant, a star
that has just recently gone
into the supergiant phase,
if it had any planets,
they should've been
sucked up and eaten.
They shouldn't be there.
But I don't know for a fact
that there aren't any there.
One of the limitations of both
the rate of velocity technique
and the transit technique is that
it requires a given orientation.
If I have, you know, if it's
orbiting this way, then it transits,
the planet passes in
front of the sun.
But if the orbit is
inclined this way,
it never transits,
there is no transit.
Likewise, the radial
velocity measurement,
if it's aligned this way,
then that star is moving back
and forth relative to
your line of sight.
But if that orbit is inclined this
direction, then it's moving this way
in your line of sight, and
you get no Doppler effect,
so you can't see it.
So there's a lot of limitations,
but it's essentially
a statistical argument
that what we're seeing is
consistent with these numbers.
If the number were
significantly higher,
we would expect to find more things.
But if there's some unexpected
unknown population of planets
out at 10 times Pluto's distance,
that we've never seen before, well,
we can't count those because
they shouldn't be there
and we haven't seen them.
>> Who's your favorite
sci-fi writer?
>> Who's my favorite
science fiction writer.
Well, that's going to
depend on whether I talk
about modern era or classic era.
In the classic era, I think
it has to be Frank Herbert.
The Dune books were always --
I have a first edition of Dune,
and that's the only first
edition I own of anything.
So that's going to
be the classic era.
In the modern era, the modern era,
I'm a huge fan of John Schultz.
But there's a lot of
good work coming out now.
It's very different than a lot
of the classic science fiction
but it's a lot of fun to read.
>> Are we the only country
studying exoplanets,
or are there other
countries doing similar things
and we share information?
>> Are we the only
country studying exoplanets
and do we share information?
Everybody and their brother
is studying exoplanets.
In fact, one of the
premier groups that has --
let me pull up the right plot.
One of the premier groups that has
made radial velocity measurements is
a group out of Geneva.
In fact, in these early days, it
was a competition between a group
at Geneva and a Carnegie
California Hawaii collaboration,
where the 2 who were competing
and seeing who could get that one
out first, and they
were neck and neck.
So it's a very international effort.
In fact, even on TESS, you saw
the OHP in France is collaborating
with us to make follow-up
observations.
We also have the E-ELT telescope
in Europe, the Japanese.
We just had the science
team meeting last week,
and the Japanese are going
to be collaborating on some
of these follow-up measurements.
Everybody wants to be involved.
In the missions, so far, the only --
there have been a few
dedicated exoplanet missions,
Kepler is the big one.
But the Europeans have flown
something called Chiaps [phonetic].
They are now in development
of a mission called Plato,
which is a lot like TESS.
It's a bigger version than TESS
and it will observe more of the sky
for longer, but it won't
launch for about another 8
or 9 years, so it's a ways away.
And they call it Plato, not
Plato, I don't know why.
And of course, they're
collaborating.
The Europeans are involved and the
Canadians are involved with JWST.
And we expect that for these kinds
of missions where the science --
I hate to say this
because it sounds so trite,
but science doesn't
have national borders.
When it comes to this data, we
share data openly and publicly,
and we don't hide anything.
Because we try to get to the truth.
So I don't care who it
is that helps me out.
It sounds so -- anyway.
Other questions?
>> That's a lovely way to end.
>> So cheesy.
>> Thank you so much, Dr. Rinehart.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.